had exactly the same experience with
connor going on the bus and everything
calmed down the bus and woke up don't
know where i was just like [ __ ] like
[ __ ] squid game like
where am i oh my god okay i'm i'm ready
i'm i'm i'm ready for
i'm ready to for the prison experience
to start so i get off and uh first thing
is that you know uh you get chauffeured
in i didn't have any armed guards just
like a bunch of like the people who
worked at the hotel who were obviously
like dexter there was no security there
was security but they weren't armed they
were just people who it looked like they
were just people who worked in the hotel
just like with a full like hazmat suit
on basically
oh yeah that's totally different okay
so so um so here's a hack if uh here's a
life hack that i i learned going through
this process is if you're if you're
traveling with someone they will give
you extra privileges and extra rooms
yeah because because connor traveled by
himself i did and i was traveling with
sydney so
uh when they sat us down and uh
gave us gave us the whole spiel of love
oh you can't do this you can't drink
alcohol you go you can't leave your room
can't open your window yada yada um and
then i was just like oh i mean me and
sydney are together can we get a bigger
room please because my god like your
room contained a double bed but i
wouldn't know it was a semi double a
semi double semi double and that took up
like the room that took up the room so i
was like there is no way i could stay
with another person in that room so me
and sydney were deciding should we just
you know say we're separate in case we
can you know in case we they do put us
in the same room um but i'm just like
let's let's see what they say we say
we're together and so i said oh i'm with
sydney can we uh stay together please
and they were like okay we'll we'll see
what we can do and uh so they go off
they go off they talk to like their
supervisor or something they come back
and then they tell us oh yeah i think we
can get you a uh we can we we can get
your room uh suited for two people and i
like that at this point the suite is
open at this point i didn't know what it
meant right so i i'm like doubling down
to be like
um is this room big enough for two
people because uh like if it is not big
enough for two people to stay in for
possibly two weeks if we test positive
for covid you know god forbid but if it
is not big enough then we would rather
have separate rooms yeah and then they
go off they go if they were like
chat chatting again uh to the supervisor
and then they come back and they will go
they go they they go
yeah i'm i'm really sorry and i'm like
okay maybe we do need to get two rooms
and we're like yeah i'm really sorry
all the king-sized beds are gone this
one only has a queen-sized bed
and i'm like
getting a five-star
can you say that again and they were
like yeah unfortunately all the
king-size sweets are gone so we're gonna
have to put you in the queen
room only has three jacuzzis the
queen-size suite are you okay with that
and i'm like
yes i like to look at the city are you
okay with that and see like i think
that's good i think that's good i'm
sorry i'm sorry
so uh we get we get taken to our room
did anyone like take you to your room no
okay we had like a guard behind us okay
so it's like smacked your ass
he's like don't look behind or you die
so we we we had like we had like we had
like four luggages with us uh like two
two big luggages and two carry-ons and
so we've been lugging them around the
[ __ ] airport and it's like heavy as
[ __ ] right and so uh after after they
check us in to our rooms uh we go pick
up they give us our meal right away
there's there's a table with all our
meals we pick one up and then me and and
then i start like putting the meal on
the suit can start lugging around and
someone goes oh no no no no no no don't
no no don't do that don't do that like
ten bags that would have been nice yeah
i was like
what's going on and then they they call
another person over and then we have
like a luggage person who puts
luggage on a trolley leads us to the
lift
and like they were like oh what room are
you checking into oh okay it's a room
301 okay that's on the third floor so
they they take us in
um he takes us into the lift presses the
button for us and then takes us out and
he says oh have a have a good stay and
i'm like have a good stay
like what's going on here so we get we
get we get up to the third floor
expecting
like me and cindy to have to take over
from there there's someone waiting for
us on the third floor
like and then they take our luggage out
and leads us to our room and before they
check us in they once again they explain
everything we can and can't do
all right and so this is this is like
the moment of truth like this is where i
find out
um i find out how big our room is right
and i'm just like i'm preparing for the
worst because i'm just like okay i'm not
going to be able to walk i'm not going
to be able to do anything japan sizes
it's japan this is right
uh we
we opened the door and it's a [ __ ]
sweet man
it's it's it's a bear in mind right
these hotels are free by the way
it's the government
like this is a hotel i would stay in if
i was on holiday right we walk in
and there's a hallway that leads to our
bed right
and
me and cindy look at each other and and
i'm just like
the gacha gods are on my side
like what is this a trash taste video
like why is he getting in the dark and
you're getting the l like like like like
the gacha gods [ __ ] smile down on me
we walk in and like there's a hallway
before we get to our room right and then
we have like a decently sized bed it's
like queen sized bed yeah yeah and then
we have an office an
office segment with like a big desk and
a massive tv
that both me and sydney can use for
desks to work in if we really wanted to
and
and we were just like
it's gonna be a great holiday
sydney this would be a great [ __ ]
holiday i i've never thought of myself
as a communist
sometimes i i wonder if they have it
right
are humans truly yes
i was so pissed off when he messaged me
a picture of his hotel room and i was
like i [ __ ] hate you
i hate you so much yeah because i
remember after i checked in um conor was
just like yo how's the room man it's
[ __ ] isn't it [ __ ] tell me a [ __ ] tell
me a [ __ ] i'm just like
i was like please tell me a [ __ ] gum
please tell me about your life right now
please tell me i'm not alone he sent me
a picture and it was like it's [ __ ]
massive no i didn't just tell him i
didn't just spend it it's not gonna rain
laps in his room i didn't just send a
picture i sent him like a video a video
tour of our room
the fact that i could send like a video
tour of our room right yeah
we live in a society we live in a
society and uh yeah we i mean we had a
lot of the same experiences but i mean
did you have a laundry surface in your
hotel oh [ __ ]
so so what we were allowed to do so uh
we had we had a receptionist right so
when we walk into the room
we noticed uh we noticed we noticed that
there's only one pillow and we're like
[ __ ]
what do we do well there's only one
pillow we can't contact anyone so i'm
just like there there's this they gave
us like a hotline in case anyone
um
in case anyone like developed symptoms
or anything like that yeah um that you
can phone
but then there's a small print that says
you can phone this this this hotline for
any other requests that you may need
during your stay as well and so
we called them up and uh they were just
like oh
how was your condition and i was like
everything's fine um there's only one
pillow in my room unfortunately and
there's two people staying here can we
get another pillow and they were just
like yeah yeah sure don't worry about it
we'll have someone deliver
we'll have someone deliver a pillow to
you like like normal hotel service and
then so we get another pillow we start
checking in we start looking at the
instructions and then we can see uh we
see that uh we can order things to our
room like we can order amazon and we can
order
deliveries as well they said i could do
that but they had like a very uh weird
list of stuff you weren't allowed to
order like burgers and pizza and chicken
you wanted my food certain foods but it
wasn't it was really oddly written that
i didn't really understand it and you
couldn't get certain things like amazon
delivered they said that you couldn't
yeah we so we we actually were able to
get amazon deliveries to our room we
couldn't get overseas we couldn't get
hot food that was like that was like the
only thing that we couldn't get which
was hot foods so we can get amazon
deliveries we can get anything that
would help our stay be more pleasant
um we had like a laundry service where
they would come collect laundry at 7am
and they would like deliver it deliver
it back to our room in the evening
we had like a garbage we had like a
garbage service that would they would
pick up garbage every morning i had my
garbage in my room
we also had a masseuse like just like
like yeah they they would like give us
new garbage bags every day
so we could fill
[Music]
and honestly our food aside from like
being cold was pretty damn [ __ ] good
we got like a got a yeah we got your
food it looked way better than mine yeah
we got like a [ __ ] decent bento every
day i mean this is something this is
like some of this [ __ ] was better than
matsuya you know like
and like how what was like the water
situation in your place did they go yeah
so so you can ask for more bottles of
water
you only got one bottle of water okay
with every meal and i ran out because i
was a thirsty boy yeah i asked for more
and they said oh sure we'll deliver it
they never delivered it yeah it just
didn't turn out so so so when we went in
oh uh so i i say our place also had a
mini fridge as well
mine did as well did yours as well okay
i think most hotels just like it just
never got cold though
it was like it's just a container yeah
so it made it like less than room
temperature which i was like i guess
that's good but like i mean what am i
gonna do come and make them replace the
[ __ ] fridge
so like we realized water would be like
a very important resource to [ __ ]
survive as as it is they said you could
use tap water but you know obviously of
you know it's just like [ __ ] in japan so
it does
um so we go in and there are there is
two bottles of water which is standard i
guess for every hotel stage i didn't
even have that you didn't no okay so
they gave us they started off with two
bottles of water and then we opened the
mini fridge and it was a mini fridge
full of bottles of water
so mine wasn't even on
turn it on so
at the start of our journey we had like
eight bottles of water which was [ __ ]
brilliant and every time they delivered
meals which was like three times a day
yeah um which was like they gave us more
food that then i needed because like by
the time i i had like the breakfast was
massive and by the time lunch was being
delivered yeah i often didn't eat
breakfast because she wasn't hungry yeah
by the by the time lunch delivered i was
still full from breakfast so i had a
little bit of lunch and then like by the
time dinner came i like i was like [ __ ]
i was eating like a [ __ ] king i don't
know like
it was it was it was a great it was a
great dichotomy that we faced this guy's
literally living like a [ __ ] like
english king during the play yeah
he's just like oh there's too much food
here guys [ __ ] me it's like you know you
know what i've seen in goodfellas where
they go well the gangsters like go to
jail yeah like they're like having like
they're like
champagne and [ __ ] that's basically
that's basically my quarantine hotel
experience it's [ __ ] great i didn't
want to leave honestly like me and
sydney woke up in the like the third day
and we're like oh [ __ ] do we do we have
to go now we have to go back twice can
one of us just get covered
it was just a free free vacation day i
didn't have didn't have to pay for it
didn't have to pay for the meals it was
a good meal every day had a
hotel service man living in the [ __ ]
grave